certainly thanks very much dick for the
warm introduction and christos dick
Alastair and the other organizers of
this event for inviting me to take part
in it it's really a wonderful collection
of perspectives on the power that the
theory of computing can have and I'm
certainly honored to be able to
contribute to that if we think about it
there's sort of a lot of ways that we
think about computing at some point I
mean during the hundredth anniversary of
Alan Turing's birth when many of us were
putting together talks with themes along
these lines I thought about some of the
images that we associate with computing
so I've laid out in some kind of
historical timeline where computing was
once something that won't you know that
was sort of conceived of in the mind of
touring and a few other people onto this
notion of human intelligence and machine
intelligence and this kind of
adversarial battle of wits and then on
through the 90s to computing of
something that really brought together
huge amounts of information and brought
together people around them right and I
think really you know at the time when I
was in grad school as the web was
beginning to emerge as this global
phenomenon you know if you had asked me
and my friends in my first year of grad
school you know what's your working
picture for the way I live in something
like this ornate library this gathering
together of all human knowledge but you
would argue that even that picture has
moved on and if we think about say the
past 10 10 10 years of our life in the
online world it's really as much been
about the crowd as the library right in
this notion of the real-time reaction of
millions of people all experiencing the
same event has become sort of a key
component of how we think about
information how we think about computing
systems right in some sense to
experience an event now is to experience
it online and to experience it online is
to really have to assemble it from the
fragmented views of these tens of
millions of people all of them reacting
to it right and so this notion of the
narrative and of an event is being
handed down top-down written in a book
representing two or three points of view
has some have been exploded into these
tens of millions of points of view and
if you lay our job to put them back
together last point about this is I
actually want to also thank you guys for
the insight of pairing Maria and me and
in the same session because I'm in
addition to my being a huge fan of the
work that Maria and enter colleagues
were doing I think some of the terrain
of the online world really is graph
theoretic and I'll try to tap into into
that to the extent i can write that in
some sense in the battle for conceptual
territory here graphs to some extent of
one right and that should be good news
for those of us who like computations on
graphs so that you know where once
people teaching a class of undergrads
would have to have explained what the
arcane dots and lines meant now one can
talk to a bunch of undergrads about
political polarization and they somehow
get that it's about this this network of
left and right bloggers and how they
talk to each other and how there's only
this forest boundary where they
communicate and when talks about
political mobilization and the spread of
activism and some of this notion of a
tree branching out and reaching many
people and recruiting them is again
something that's both graph theoretic
and yet something that would that we
understand and so I think all these
things are bundled together this notion
that this territory that the online
world covers it's a somehow
simultaneously Geographic its social
right social and economic and its graph
theoretic and that means a few things
one is it means that when we go to
design these systems we need to think
about the challenge of designing not
just with the kind of constraints that
we've always dealt with with big
computing systems but we also need to
think about the constraints imposed by
the feedback loops that arise from human
behavior right the incentives and the
kind of social network structures that
form and all of these are now part of
the design process always probably the
constraints that we're operating under
and the second of course is that when
all this data comes together we learn
about ourselves right and we learn you
know we learn in some deep sense what
political polarization looks like in a
way that's somehow more quantitative and
deeper than we had understood before we
learn what
act of mobilization on the scale of
thousands or millions look like in a way
that's deeper than we did before and a
lot of that is our ability to collect
this kind of data and think about it
okay so I want to talk about some of the
models that we used to think about this
kind of data and some of what we've
learned from it and I also wanted to try
to tap into you know a succession of
talks of really enjoyed throughout the
day looking at different aspects of how
computation can help us understand
different scientific phenomena and I
guess one contrast I draw is that one
has to remember that science of course
you know has has a great power to
illuminate things that are inaccessible
to us right inaccessible to our
intuition right our genomes quantum
effects or bring you know the function
of our brains things happening a huge
galactic length scales but of course
part of the the entry here part of the
challenge is that it can also
potentially help illuminate things that
are extremely familiar to us right and
they saw this irony that as little as we
understand about genomes or deep space
astronomy we also understand comparably
little about how humans social groups
function despite the fact that we that
is the world that we live in right and
that's I think also part of what we're
trying to we're trying to hear okay so
with that as context that's how I want
to think about it I want to think about
what can L guerrillas and computation do
when faced with data on us right face
with data on our own behavior what can
we learn from it how do we model it and
in thing about that I'm often when I
sort of started out think about what is
the challenge of an algorithm faced with
modeling us right in your design albums
to do this I think back to a actually a
lecture I heard 20 years ago the spring
when I was in college Carl Sagan spoke
on campus and
cornell even for Cornell undergrads like
like myself abilities to see Carl Sagan
despite the fact that he lived in Ithaca
were often kind of rare since he
traveled widely and he spoke on campus
and it was this fascinating lecture in
the lecture was entitled is there life
on Earth right sort of it unexpected
title he was talk about a paper he had
published in nature nature had put that
same question on its cover is there life
on Earth this is the beginning of that
paper research he the title slightly
expanded on his point was actually a
search for life on Earth from the
Galileo spacecraft and what was going on
here well so the Galileo spacecraft was
going to go out to the outer reaches of
the solar system and maybe beyond and
you know the and you know the people
planning it's rude had decided that what
was going to work best with some kind of
elaborate slingshot through the inner
solar system it would kind of pick up
speed around I forget Mercury Venus and
head back out and out to the outer solar
system and in the process it actually
passed over the earth and you know as it
passed over the earth that turned its
formidable battery of measuring
instruments down on the surface and it
recorded a whole bunch of stuff and then
moved on and it transmitted all that
back back down to people monitoring the
mission and Carl Sagan's question with
his co-authors here was that you know
this is a good control experiment if
we're going to go out and try to look
for evidence of life on the moons of
Jupiter or Saturn then at the very least
we ought to be able to tech detect
evidence for life on Earth because you
know that that would be a good kind of
you know just debugging of this whole
plan and so he asked us in this lecture
to imagine that we are in a we the
audience sitting in Bailey Hall in the
Cornell campus are an audience full of
Martian scientists and he's a Martian
scientist telling us about the readings
he's just discovered coming from Earth
and he talked about oxygen methane
balances and what that might signify and
a whole bunch of things and this this
this metaphor that we're looking at
something we're asking what could you
have learned if this was all the data
you had me and so often now I find
myself thinking about Martian scientists
right but my Martian scientists are
algorithms they're things that are
getting the digital emissions coming off
the surface of the earth and the
question is if this was all you had what
would you learn it would you be learning
the right
right and this life on Earth question I
think is sort of useful because it's
often worth asking would we learn the
right things on stuff we know about so
that when we start venturing into
aspects of our behavior that we know
relatively little about we might also
see the right things so with that in
mind I want to actually start with some
work that Dave Crandall dan hunt lock
realize backs when I did a few years ago
that as part of it had sort of this life
on Earth flavor and then I'll move into
things that are a little more remote
from our experience although still about
human social behavior right so this was
the idea we were thinking about large
photo collections and there were a few
of us doing this actually the group of
us at Cornell were think about this also
here in the Bay Area Linden candy and
more in Amman we're asking asking
similar question of photo collections
one you can do with photo collections is
there geotagged you up you know your
phone might have a GPS when you take the
picture where you might just mark it on
a map where it was so I could imagine a
big blank canvas it's black and what
I'll do is I'll put a dot where each
photo was taken okay so a white dot and
this was 2009 we're looking at Flickr
you would now you can now do this for
Facebook for example where basically the
entire contents of Flickr is uploaded in
equivalent volume every few weeks much
greater density of coverage ok dot on
map if you put all those dots down to
map simultaneously and you step back
then shapes start to appear right and
the shapes look like kind of like that
ok so this is again one dot for each
each of these things and of course you
know the fact that you see a map here is
in some sense only in your mind what's
really here is just a bunch of dots on
on a canvas but of course there are a
few things that we can recognize I
actually want to recognize these for you
know maybe later use also right so what
do we see we see you know people take
pictures up to you know certain physical
limitations and then no further release
relatively few take them further some
people are in boats or in airplanes
right and we certainly see that meet
these coastlines you know for the same
reason this region is strangely black
and I'll let you figure out why that is
we see certain places where the dots
pile up right these densities these hot
spots right in hot spots are certainly
one thing I think you should always look
for when you're looking
this kind of data you also see one
dimensional threads right and we see a
one dimensional thread something's going
on there right maybe there's a river
maybe there's a mountain range but
there's something running through that
that might explain you know why in one
case people all travel here and take
photos or live here and take photos here
affluent tourists with their digital
cameras all fly to a certain place climb
mountains and take photos these kind of
shapes emerge okay so this was our
starting point for a a kind of life on
Earth picture now I said the terrain
here is geographic as it clearly is here
but it's also in a sense social and this
point was made very nicely in some work
that um stanley milgram did the 1970s
person I seem to keep bumping into
stanley milgram's work from a variety of
angles this is not his not his work on
the 60s of separation or obedience to
authority it says work on people's
psychological representations of cities
and he said the city is a social fact we
would all agree to that that's actually
giving all of us a lot of credit but we
would also need to add important car
Larry the perception of city is also a
social fact and he was talking about
some work where he actually walked
around Paris asking people to draw their
mental map of what Paris of like so
residents of Paris they said you know
just please sketch for me you know what
you think of Paris and you know draw
some landmarks if you want and you know
so for example this person actually did
pretty well they got the curve of the
San almost completely right they kind of
understood that this person thought of
it is basically straight right for them
they had mentally straighten the sand
into the axis along which Paris runs and
all of these are sort of people's mental
representations and so the question is
could we somehow say something out these
collective mental representations from
the kind of data that you see on a photo
sharing site so the idea was the
following to start with these hot spots
these hot spots I showed you right in
here right here we see a similar thing
rotate over the west part of the Western
Hemisphere and we've tried this with a
bunch of things with photos with search
engine queries a bunch stuff like this
i'll stick to photos for our life on
Earth experiment here and so we could
ask
maybe three things one is where are the
hot spots in the picture second can I
rank them by intensity where the most
interesting points are and third what's
special about each one can I find a good
description of each one all right and
again because I'm sort of trying to
cover you know ground that we we have
some intuition for before moving on to
more social domains let me just run
through roughly how we did this so the
first thing finding hot spots there are
a number ways to do this one one tricky
part here is that there are hundreds
actually thousands of meaningful hot
spots on the surface of the earth in
this photo sharing collection so we want
some local search algorithm that's very
very multimodal and one nice thing is
this thing called the mean shift
algorithm which basically puts down a
whole bunch of disks on the points where
the pictures were taken and then each
disk begins to slide in the direction of
greater density right so you look at
what's the points in your circle and you
move the center toward the center of
gravity of what you've encompassed right
if you're on a gradient of density that
will move the center toward where it
gets denser and eventually circles will
pile up here and they'll pile up here
and here and so we'll find these
hotspots and the more circles at lamb
they are somehow the more more dense it
was we'd like to talk about what's at
the hot spots and so distinctive
features we one thing we can do is look
at textual tags photos are tagged with
text let's see what people have to say
about this and of course no matter where
you are in the earth most tags still say
something like trip vacation friends
stuff like that which is not really
descriptive of the hot spot right so we
need to be a bit more subtle and so a
better algorithm would be to employ
Bayes rule and say what we really want
to ask is which hotspot is least sort of
likely relative to the background
radiation of tags right tags are
emanating from all over the earth and
everywhere all around the earth they say
trip and vacation and so forth so let's
say if tags would generate this point
according to the world's background
radiation which would be the least
likely observation right so everywhere
people say trip but only here two people
say it
say eiffel tower with anywhere near this
density and so if a coin with the bias
of eiffel tower were flipped all around
the world here it just be very very
unlikely how to see that many heads so
eiffel tower is special at exactly this
point okay and we can do similar things
to find distinctive photos at a location
and again we were pulling together tools
that existed in the case of the image
processing and particularly some nice
work by my now colleague at cornell noah
snavely with steve sites at risk Rick
stilinski okay so of course you may want
to know what happened so what we did we
used we did mean shift we took 100
kilometer disk so we move them all
around the earth and we tried to find
where they piled up the most and we
pulled out textual tags that were at
least likely given the background
radiation of tags coming off the earth
and then within that hundred kilometers
we open that up and we took hundred
meter disks and we move them around and
tried to find the biggest density and
found what what stood out so let me on
the next slide draw for you a table
which is the 20 hottest hot spots at the
hundred kilometer range what tag
described them and then the top 400
hundred meter landmarks okay now I built
in those two scales hundred kilometers
sort of a metro city range 100 meters is
the range which you sort of see
something to take a picture of it right
okay and this is right so again this is
created purely by the algorithm from the
data that was sort of no intervention by
us we just sort of aimed this thing at
all the tanks going off so these are the
top 20 hot spots and what the most
improbable tag was right the one that
most deviated from the background
radiation and then here are the top for
landmarks at the hundred meter scale
and each of these okay some things to
notice right so actually a whole bunch
of these notes this is obviously not you
know the most significant places on the
earth but among the internet photo
uploading population of the earth I have
to make that clear you know so no
offense to the fine city that were cross
the bay from but San Francisco does show
up third because boy do people love to
upload photos to the internet also of
course you know Mayim hatton here the
fourth landmark apple store you know
maybe not on everyone's list of the top
floor landmarks in New York City but for
people with iphones it's a pilgrimage
you go there you take the photo you
upload it and you get a really really
intense hot spot there so we're seeing a
blend right we're seeing we're learning
about the world but it's all as always
it's sort of torque by the online engine
but not torque very much right this is a
completely credible description of
landmarks on the earth and so it's in a
sense telling us to go back to the
Martians you know yes right there is
enough data in a photo sharing site that
Martians could build reasonable tour
guides to to the world okay so and we
can put these on a map right at at this
point you see this new thing wouldn't be
nice if we could take you know those
children's jigsaw puzzles if you've seen
the map of the United States which has
little states you put together and has
like a radar on the outside has a
picture of Mount Rushmore and a picture
of the Golden Gate Bridge and everything
right it's sort of like this panorama
oughtn't we'd be able to build that so
we take again this picture and we
annotate it right and you can build that
sort of thing again this is purely from
the data right so this now the 20
biggest hotspots in north america new US
and canada with the name and the name of
the biggest landmark right so here we
have this place that's apparently called
busting which apparently has something
called fenway park it looks like this
writing again the same algorithm you aim
it at Europe you know you get the same
thing you can zoom in you get me an
Hatton
right and we learn there's actually two
lower Manhattan right and so the point
is you know it it says when we have
something we have some intuition about
that kind of data were collecting with
the right algorithms right we have to be
careful we have to we had to sort of
correctly use local optimization to find
the hotspots way to correctly use the
right proble stick model to actually
named them so that they didn't get dumb
names right but when you use it in this
way you can actually learn something
right and it's sort of this picture of
these disks floating out over the world
and settling over you know the Statue of
Liberty and Fenway Park and you know and
I I used to see you know the beginning
of almost every sort of bad science
fiction movie you've ever seen right
what are the first 10 minutes consists
of the alien UFOs coming in and circling
over the earth there they are hovering
over the Taj Mahal the pyramids there's
the reporter stand there but we'll dUrd
with UFO behind going you know they've
just they showed up this morning right
you think wait a minute how did the
aliens you know no to go hover over the
pyramids and the Taj Mahal and you know
it's not as hard as you think right you
know so they can even feel what we call
so okay so all right so this was a
picture which was Geographic which was
social and where we've learned some
things about about the world as we
understand it I want to bring network
structure back into the picture because
in the end some of what's going on is
going to need some deeper understanding
of the kind of interactions to happen
among people the kind of collaborations
the kind of convergences of social
phenomena produced certain effect right
so we want to understand some very
complex social phenomenon which produced
a footprint on social media such as the
Arab Spring right such as the Egyptian
revolution in 2011 which was where
there's an extensive trace of tweets and
other things that we can look at we're
gonna need to understand some of the
graph structures right and and certainly
two big graph structures that we always
think about here one is the graph of
essentially who knows whom the social
network right a link between two people
when they're friends right nodes are
people links herbs and friends
and another one is the kind of who knows
about what graph right that's different
that's the you know I am aware of this
person I follow them on Twitter and so I
can get for example someone in the
second graph who has a degree in the
millions millions of people linked to
them because they're all aware of that
person where is the first one it's a
social network it's really based on
individual acquaintance right both of
these are clearly going to be important
for us to think about okay so
essentially the strange geography of our
collective social experience all right
so let me talk about a first kind of
graph that's useful to look at you go on
to a social networking site where you've
asked people to you know link to their
friends take Facebook and rather than
look at the entire graph which is
unbelievably complicated let's look at
one person's network neighborhood okay
so this is you all of your friends and
the links among your friends right so
the induced sub graph on on the set of
your friends in facebook okay so here's
what one such picture looks like this
was actually an picture produced by
Cameron Marlow and his co-authors that
on the data science team at Facebook it
was actually derived from it was a
facebook engineer who basically donated
his network to science so that we could
look at it here this is all of his
friends and this is this is the clusters
among them I was actually struck um
Maria was talking about her favorite
graph on 99 vertices you know and in
some for a real sense this guy at the
center right this is his favorite graph
on it most 99 bercy's right this is the
graph he understands arguably the best
in the entire world right so he knows
what this cluster is this is his
coworkers these are actually his old
friends from college right there's not
much connection between the two of them
right his old friends and college
somehow distinct from the people he
works with now somewhere in here is his
extended family somewhere here are old
friends who span different these things
we can learn a lot about this person's
life simply from looking at the way that
these clusters are laid out we could
tell stories about it okay and and what
I want to argue actually is that this is
a useful way to think about gigantic
social networks okay that
we get some mileage out of thinking of
Facebook as a 1 billion node network
right that's a that's a useful
projective sometimes we can ask about
degrees of separation how far apart are
we but in some sense at some level it is
really incomprehensible at that scale
and so instead I want for a while used
to think about it as a collection of
these network neighborhoods right a
billion people each with their own
100-person Network neighborhood right so
Facebook is a collection of a billion
small networks each of our network
neighborhoods all overlapping in
different ways okay and one thing that's
interesting here is when we go to think
about graphs this way certain mantras
that we've picked up from studying big
social networks start to go away so for
example this notion of graphs as
enormous but sparse right that's
certainly true I think of the billion
node facebook graph each of us is linked
to only a few hundred people at most
right so they are you know the degree we
should think of a sort of a constant
compared to the graph going to infinity
but I think about network neighborhoods
a very large fraction of your pairs of
friends actually do know each other they
actually have a link and so these are
small graphs that are also dense and
that's kind of appealing because there's
a of course gigantic body of literature
on things we know about dense graphs and
how to work with them that have been
sort of kept from coming into play with
this work on social networks because
social norms have been enormous and
sparse but if we think about families of
small dense graphs like this we can
start to think about things in that way
and so one way we can think about that
is to think about induced subgraphs
right so here as in the previous talk
induced subgraphs will come back in the
picture I might want to if I have a
billion of these I want to somehow write
down a small set of coordinates by which
I can map them I might want to project
this graph down to a very small set of
features okay and one that's kind of
systematic would be to enumerate all
possible small graphs and here I mean
very small graphs graphs on three nodes
graphs on four nodes okay and for every
small three or four node graph or small
K node graph I could hook at this number
f G of H which is the fraction of knode
subsets that induce a copy of age
okay that makes it becomes a kind of
signature for for the graph right so you
know here's what looks like so for
example I'd say all right pick you know
every triple of nodes this one for
example what is it induce induces an
edge and two non edges so it would be an
example of this right and so this these
are the four possible graphs on three
nodes and so I'd be boiling this picture
down to a four dimensional vector
actually one in which the coordinates
add up to one so it's effectively a
three dimensional structure right the
set of all possible things that this
could become is a thing with four
numbers but it's it's a three
dimensional object it's the three
simplex and there are 11 possible graphs
on four nodes I don't expect you to know
that but that's all of them and I could
similarly look at that that vector 11
numbers that add up to 1 okay all right
and you know these these have certain
certain meanings right so if we think
about in the context of social network
structure right so triangles we know are
quite common in in in social networks
for all sorts of reasons right if you
have two people you know there's a
tendency for you to introduce them to
each other this is intensity for them to
meet each other that's this process
called triadic closure that what tends
to happen is structures like this over
time tend to become structures like that
as these two people meet each other for
any of a variety of reasons right once
you have friends in common right this
also somehow meaningful because we sort
of see why we get a lot of those in
social networks from this picture right
every time I pick one node for one big
cluster and two nodes from the other I
get one of these right so certain things
are more likely certain things are less
likely and and actually if we sort of
play around with this picture let me
just sort of proposed one more thing to
you and this actually harks back to yet
one more thing from the last talk which
is when we think about graphs also think
about compliments and what they tell us
right and obviously you know every time
one of these it's common to one of these
so a common thing that people's network
neighborhoods look like is you've got
your friends from work and your
ends from you know where you live or
your old you know whatever they are and
so lots of network neighborhoods look
roughly like you know two things that
are close to being cleats maybe a lot of
other noise around here right but that's
that's a common picture right that's
very rich in these things and those
things and it's relatively sparse in
these things in those things but that
doesn't mean those are impossible right
in principle your network neighborhood
could look like a complete bipartite
graph now let me suggest you that that
is extremely unlikely right that would
mean that you have these two bunches of
people you know and all the ones are
here are friends with all the ones over
there and vice versa right that simply
doesn't happen so what we have to
understand is there are certain things
which are properties of graphs and
they're certainly with your properties
of people and part of the interesting
challenge here when we go to map out
social network neighborhoods is to
separate which is which if we're seeing
a certain thing that does not happen in
our social network data is it because
graphs don't do that or because people
don't do that all right and you can get
both kinds right in particular you know
large parts of this are somehow large
parts of the space of possible
neighborhoods feel kind of unpopulated
all right so unpopulated sort of starts
to creep precariously into these
metaphors about population density and
geography so let me make them concrete
right we have a space here which
fortunately is a three-dimensional space
I could draw it right so what do all
Network neighborhoods on Facebook
actually look like so you know let's go
around collect huge numbers of these so
we get kind of a nice density of
coverage and let's plot them in this 3d
space where they live if we look at try
at frequencies right we can also go up
to the 10 dimensional space for quad
frequency so let's stay here now there
are various ways to draw this I'm not
gonna claim I necessarily pick the best
one but in in some joint work with Johan
Uganda and Lars Backstrom we set out to
map the space I'm trying to stand any
bit about what it looks like and here's
what we here's what we tried so the
three axes are three of the pure sub
graph so I've left out the the fourth
one the wedge graph okay so I've amid
did this one this one that happens a lot
in by part 2 complete bipartite graphs
happens lesson in social networks okay
all right so every one of our
neighborhoods right is a point somewhere
in here it's the density of these things
they didn't see those things identity of
those things and the missing one minus
the sum of those is the density of
widgets ok so we put them all in and we
get a shape like that ok all right so
this is in the sense right this is the
sort of human manifold that runs through
a larger ambient space of possible
network shapes that our network
neighborhoods could look like ok and
let's go back to our intuition from the
picture right the earth viewed from
space via a photo sharing site right
what are some things we learn from that
well we should look for coastlines right
coastlines are the physical constraints
on you can go this far and no farther
and so for example one thing that we
proved as part that Johan Larsson I
proved as far doing this which
admittedly is not that hard to prove
from the moon moser theorem in extremo
graph theory is that this one edge triad
this thing cannot occur at a frequency
of more than 34 days ok it's a nice fact
that you can try proving right so you
can't have a graph in which every try it
induces one of those and you can't even
graph in which more than three-quarters
of the Triads induce one of those ok so
there's a cut here which actually this
thing creeps up pretty close to so this
coastline up here is pretty much a graph
theoretic constraint not a human
constraint but again take compliments
that also says you know a complete by
222 just joined equal size clicks would
achieve this a complete bipartite graph
would have the the wedge the one that's
not drawn here that guy in a complete
bipartite graph the wedgwood have
density three quarters and again you can
kind of work that out for yourself that
would again that's the missing
dimensions we have to just imagine it
would be sort of coming close down
toward the origin here that's a big
unpopulated part of the space right
people could live there but they don't
because their network neighborhoods
don't look like complete bipartite
subgroups
okay and so we thought about this and I
should mention obviously the natural
question is well couldn't you draw for
us the full feasible region that is a
very very hard problem and it contains
as special cases very hard problems
including this very very nice result of
res borrow from 2007 who characterized
what is what are the possible densities
of triangles right these guys as a
function of the density of edges in the
graph now if I knew how to describe the
full feasible region of all tried
frequencies I would know the edge
density and I would know the triangles
as a function of yet jency and I would
be saying something more general than
that so a description of that is
actually seems quite challenging
although i should mention and this is
only for those who are into these kind
of results when you actually project it
down i didn't draw this picture here
projected down onto the axes rasbora
views in his paper edge density and
triangle density some of the intricate
scalloping of the boundary you can
almost imagine might be showing up in
simply in the way people have
constructed their neighborhoods and so
there's an intriguing thing about how
much how much these boundaries actually
get carved down all right but when i
mention one more thing that we we
learned from the geography right which
was what this is sort of a and actually
as the network of neighborhoods get
bigger this tightens up this sort of is
a one dimensional thread traveling
through space and it gets thinner and
thinner as Pete as you get people with
bigger and bigger neighborhoods okay and
when you see a one-dimensional thread
you should ask what is the river or
mountain range or interstate highway
that they're all living near right and
in this case GNP the artist rainy graph
is effectively the river that the human
beings are living along okay all right
so GNP runs through this like a nerve
down the middle right like the river so
we're all the photos coalesce but of
course not quite right in and actually
it's bit of a surprise for us to see
this because as has been endlessly
recounted the Irish rainy graph is not
such a great description of human social
networks but the point is that certainly
is true if I think about large sparse
networks but as I get down to these
small dense Network neighborhoods there
is still this clustering and so it's not
exactly right but it starts to get
closer okay starts to get within each of
those clusters and that guy's life right
his
coworker subgraph his old friends of
school subgraph erdos-renyi starts to
become a better and better approximation
of that right it's an amorphous blob of
people who all you know mainly know each
other but people don't live completely
on the river there's a deviation and
that deviation is exactly too many
triangles and too much of this stuff
which is again those disjoint leagues
right so thats signature of triangle
formation and clustering shows up is
what about deviations from that nerve
that runs down the middle okay so this
is the kind of structure that we do be4
all p the other yeah thnkx so if i think
about yeah i actually let's think about
excellent question let think about GNP
GNP the free variable here is P and that
gives me a parametric curve in the space
because the density of triangle is P
cubed and the density of wedges is 3p
squared 1 minus P and so forth and so I
get a parametric curve for variables
cubic and it's actually does have this
nice kind of torsion that you get out of
this kind of nice cubic curve right in
the middle yep exactly okay so yeah you
tell me the edge density and then then
we'll see that right and again each of
these in a sense you are here I should
mention there's some coloration here
they're actually three things that we
that we plot on top of each other they
all sit nicely on top of each other
network neighborhoods and two other
kinds of sub graphs small dense
subgraphs you see on facebook groups
right users form groups there's a social
network induced there and events right
you host an event on Facebook people say
yes you look at the induced sub graph on
that and they're all sort of lying in
the same narrow one-dimensional thread
okay
let me move on to what we can do with
some of this right so this is the space
all right this is the space that we're
looking at space we're trying to map
that we're trying to learn something
about I want to talk about how you can
use some of this to talk about how
information flows through these networks
because if I think about a site like
Facebook we're like Twitter or any of
social media site like that in a sense
they have signed on to a transport
mechanism for their content that is an
ascent social right where you know where
we architected networks and we said the
transport mechanism is tcp/ip the
transport mechanism is circuit switched
or packet switched those are all running
down below but what's actually getting
the content into people's hands on
facebook or on twitter is a kind of
social reshoring mechanism I hear
something I share with my friends its
Fred's right a kind of contagion that's
happening at the level of people's
decision-making and not at the level of
something technological and so if we
want understand how information reaches
people in this kind of world then we
want to understand how this transport
mechanism works right and it's this sort
of same transfer mechanism that we've
seen in many domains across across
history right there's a long history of
research in how things spread by word of
mouth beginning arguably in the field of
sociology where they refer to it as the
diffusion of innovations and and this
diffusion of innovations has in a sense
it's sort of or document this paper by
Ryan and gross 1943 where they cross the
Midwest interviewing farmers about when
they adopted hybrid seed corn right
hybrid seed corn was an innovation it
was something had to decide to try
planting on your farm and it was risky
because you know your corn grew pretty
well you made that was where you made
your money you're going to try something
new you risk you know you risk financial
trouble and so you're more likely to do
it if someone you know has done it and
it worked out right and so they actually
this is the hand-drawn plot from their
paper of when do people actually adopt
hybrid seed corn by hearing about from
their friends and and the point was you
know there was a wave of hearing about
it this is the percentage of people who
knew about hybrid seed corn and what it
could do and this is
at the slower wave with people adopted
it we said there's a difference between
knowing and adopting the first time you
hear about it you might not do it it
might take you a few hearings you may
need to be convinced right and moving on
from there we now have many many
examples in the online domain right work
on media influence right happy how
things spread by word of mouth which
again has a rich history going back to
the 40s work on you know social activism
how people recruit each other by word of
mouth online and the whole topic of
virality right the way things become
viral news and rumors marketing
strategies and hope to become viral
political messages that aspire to become
viral right things that we can map out
using this kind of online data right the
spread of a recommendation for
particular Japanese anime novel the
spread of an anti-war chain letter all
of them pushing out through the network
by this kind of mechanism with this long
history okay so we'd like to think about
what is sort of a reasonable model for
how some of this works and can we see
evidence for that model in the kind of
data that work that they were collecting
here so one thing to notice from the
Ryan and gross work on hybrid seed corn
adoption people heard about it but it
took a few hearings and a few
observations before they really did
something about it before they really
adopted it and so a model that people
have talked about for that kind of
process and 111 which I've now thought
about for several years is the notion of
threshold contagion okay this notion
that you're probably of adopting a
behavior adopting hybrid seed corn
forwarding the anti-war petition
recommending the book to your friends
all these things grows with the number
of people you've observed doing it right
the first person may or may not have an
impact on you the second one more so and
and so forth and it grows right this and
it is a model that you've seen proposed
in the marketing literature and
sociology and economics quite famous
people have separately in their
different fields argued for this kind of
a picture right and it produces if you
you know open up shellings micromotors
in macro behavior book you'll see
cartoon pictures like this and the
cartoon picture says imagine on the
x-axis is the number of friends I've I
have who've adopted this thing right who
have signed the petition or bought the
product and this is the probability you
know for this number friends that if I
come back in the next time period and
observe you you know you will have in
fact on it and the question people
looked at even if the level of these
cartoon pictures was you know there are
several shapes the cadet we could have a
diminishing return shape where the first
hearing of it the second hearing of it
those are the most forceful and after a
while it sort of tapers off or could
have a critical mass kind of effect
where you know the first few aren't so
crucial but you know three and four and
five that's really when I really become
more likely to adopt it one question is
it was sort of intriguing that 1970s
you're always seeing pictures as though
these curves really existed but of
course we were very very far framing the
kind of data where you could actually
look at this because you're probably
doing anything is very low and so the
noise you would have to get rid of in
the system is extensive and the data
simply wasn't there and it wasn't there
in fact for 30 more years but before I
move on to pictures let me point out
that actually we have very little
understanding of these simple threshold
models and so I want to mention some
intriguing questions that arise when we
think about these things okay so what is
a threshold model it says everybody has
some threshold which they're going to
adopt I which the contagion will affect
it which they'll adopt the innovation
right they'll sign the petition so I
imagine a graph
and I magic everyone randomly produces a
threshold which is the moment at which
they are going to tip right so someone
has a special of two they need to see
two friends do this thing before they
join in all right someone draw the
threshold of zero that means they're
going to spontaneously do it right there
an early adopter they don't need to see
friends doing and so here's a question
you can ask and it's it's nice and that
it's a model i can write down in half a
slide and you'll get what I'm talking
about but its behavior is actually still
largely an open question i can actually
pose for you quite quite simple open
questions okay so i have a graph each
node V has a just has d neighbors I
picked that for simplicity because i
want to take no degree out of the
picture but we could enrich that if you
wanted I want to keep this simple each
node V chooses a threshold F of V at the
start from a distribution over the
possible thresholds right and that's the
threshold at which it's going to join in
the contagion which it's going to adopt
so V will adopt as soon as it has F of V
neighbors who adopted right so you know
take for example three regular graphs
take this disk leak if the thresholds
were 0 1 2 & 4 then what would happen
this guy would spontaneously adopt it
would cause this guy to adopt the in the
next step this person would have two
neighbors adopting they'd adopt this
person of course has it has a special
before they would never adopt they're
impervious okay if you imagine this as
say the infinite ternary tree so it too
is a three regular graph although an
infinite one you know a similar thing
happens I'm not quite sure what's going
down here but these two zeros trigger
this one who together with the zero
triggers that one the process stops
that's the process and and that's the
whole process and it's parametrized by
two things right a graph G and a
distribution mute if I tell you those
two things you can run this process and
you can ask whatever there is to be
asked about about this kind of thing
okay and yet despite how simple it is to
formulate this and this really it's
challenging it's challenging to analyze
and it's particularly daunting because
it's somehow is at the heart of any
model you would want to build for this
right anything you I built for this says
people are heterogeneous in their
response to what's going on in the graph
right so there's a there's an arbitrary
graph and people are heterogeneous and
as soon as you try to do anything that
uses those ingredients you end up with
something that has this as a special
case and this is hard okay and so this I
think becomes a variance ting and I was
actually intrigued that in in in les
valiance talk this morning when he's
talking about brain networks something
which was maybe not exactly this but
awfully close to this comes into play
where I'm looking at units in some
neural architecture and I'm asking when
does this fire and if fire is when a
certain threshold is reached and so
threshold contagion is not only a social
phenomenon but it's been employed in
studies of neural activation it's been
sight elsewhere it's been studied in the
robustness of power grids and financial
markets where this would be a threshold
was with something fails and that
failure may propagate in cascade onward
me many many contacts we've run into
this into this thing and relatively
little is known and I want to mention
one open question here which i think is
intriguing so some things which we do
understand better there's some work that
we did actually leading some very nice
work of it elephant in Mosul and
Sebastian Roke here the case where
there's a diminishing returns effect
they say a distribution that tries to
capture this where the first few
exposure is the most important obviously
special case results if the graph is a
tree or lattice or a click although i
should mention not the special case
results here are not such that i could
really somehow compare or trees to klieg
and that and that's what we wanted to do
so in some work with Larry bloom david
easily Bobby Kleinberg and Ava tardish
we want to understand arbitrary graphs
and well understand if I fix the
distribution which graphs have more or
less contagion probability
right so for a given distribution miu
over how the heterogeneity works in
people's adopting behavior which graphs
are gonna be the most susceptible to
contagion and which will be the least
susceptible to contagion okay and it
turned out there are somewhat subtle
trade-offs here based on differences in
network neighborhoods right so this will
come back again to the landscape of
possible network neighborhoods that a
graph can exhibit and to give an idea of
what's going on here let me just tell
you about two different network
neighborhoods the kind of neighborhood
you see in a click we're all neighbors
are connected and the kind of a weird
see in a tree which is completely open
where no neighbors are connected okay
and it turns out one or the other can
have higher contagion probability
depending what the distribution looks
like okay so let me think around think
about all possible distributions let me
do something very very simple and just
think about premature izing
distributions using all these two
variables so there's a probability that
node will have zero probably have one
and the rest of the masses on probably
too okay and I could ask in which is the
contagion probably hotter in the klique
or in the infinite tree okay and if I
want the bus be infinite graphs maybe
this is a countable union of clicks this
is a single infinite tree okay and the
answer is it actually depends and in
fact if I think about a graph so let's
actually here's sort of the one here's
sort of let's go one more step and just
think to make sure we get the definition
suppose that with probably s in your
graph get a threshold of 0 and with
their main probability at a threshold of
one okay now that's a very easy kind of
contagion to understand people with zero
spontaneously go on they adopt everyone
else has a threshold of one and so any
any connected component of this graph
where someone starts with the official
zero it rips through the whole component
because everything else has a threshold
of one okay so if I talk about a
distribution we're probably s of 0 1
minus s of 10 everywhere else that just
says you switch on if anyone your
component spontaneously switch them and
if you want to minimize the probability
contagion you should have a connected
component that's as small as possible in
that situation you would like a
quarantine strategy and a quarantine
strategy says make little clicks that
are isolated from each other
it turns out that also for more subtle
reasons is true if all the probabilities
are zero or two if everything is either
a 0 or 2 it turns out similarly you want
to quarantine if you want to minimize
the probably contagion and clicks
minimize the field the surprise is that
this is very far from being convex if I
average these two in the right way so i
have a small probability of 0 a slightly
bigger but small probability of 1 and
then the main probability on two turns
out there's actually a lower probability
of the contagion say reaching this node
in the infantry then in the klique and i
won't go into the details of why but the
intuition somehow is that when I have
this I get these ricochet effects like
you see here if I can get zeros ones and
twos so what can happen is zero turns on
one and that's kind of like a pilot
light sort of effect right zero
activates one and that activates two and
that can't happen in the tree because
your neighbors are completely
uncorrelated so if you're going to
activate with a special 22 you have to
get hit from two completely separate
independent directions if these problems
are low that's unlikely to happen okay
and it turns out that for the right
setting of parameters you would rather
be in an infinite component with
uncorrelated neighbors than in a very
small component with correlated
neighbors and so trying to understand
where these trade-offs kick in and for a
given threshold attribution which
topologies have higher or lower
contagion probability is something which
already exposes a bunch of subtleties
Yvonne very very simple instances and is
not something that we understand that we
understand very well so a bunch of open
questions here I want to move on to
something I meant to the question of can
you actually use some of these threshold
models to actually look at data and look
at probably of adoption and do we
actually see neighborhood shape come
into play to actually see something
about structural diversity or your
neighbors connected or are they not
connected does it actually also show up
in
in this kind of data okay so can we use
this kind of thing for prediction tasks
predicting who's going to adopt some new
thing right if I'm say marketing a
product I'm doing social advertising I'm
trying to push a political message and
does the diversity of neighborhoods
actually actually matter okay so I
mentioned when people originally drew
these cartoons we were 30 years from
having data where we could even remotely
look at what these kind of things look
like but now we have that data because
any kind of social network where people
are making decisions about new behaviors
over time really is something where we
could actually ask this kind of this
kind of question okay so I imagine you
know joining a group in an online
community deciding to use a certain
hashtag liking a particular piece of
content all of them consist of the
following picture there's a big social
network and some people have already
adopted the behavior they use the
hashtag they joined the community
they're inside the big pink cloud the
big pink clouds expanding recruiting new
members new people who use the hashtag
or sign the petition and these people
are all exposed to the pink cloud this
person has three friends who've used it
this has this person is one and I could
ask you know who's more likely if I come
back in the next time step to have
adopted the new behavior x y z how do
they differ right x and y have three
friends rosie has one x has clustered
neighbors why has an open neighborhood
who are not connected how does all that
come together right can I do something
there ok and so when we first asked this
question we actually just thought about
number of friends right x and y have
three easy has one let's go back to that
picture and starting in 2006 you know to
our delight we could actually finally
draw these pictures and again it was a
little intimidating because you know you
hope once you started drawing them you
know at least hopefully the curve would
go up you know it kind of do the right
thing and what was reassuring is that
you know the first few pictures which
came about the
and and other people you are a less
kovitch a lot of damage Bernardo
Huberman and others did in 2006 actually
looked sort of like the cartoons from
shellings book right that you saw this
kind of diminishing return shape you saw
some other interesting behavior right
around zero there's other issues you can
ask and I'll skip over a slide that
talks about some nice experiments the
people did it at a Facebook last year a
ton back skewness co-authors where they
actually tried to distinguish between
Caza they try to understand some of the
causality problems here right namely is
is it that your friends caused you to do
this or simply that knowing you have
three friends who like this thing gives
me better predictive leverage right so
by manipulating but you show people you
can actually start to disentangle those
effects I'll jump over that to talk
about this issue that I've been kind of
trying to foreshadow which is these open
versus closed Network neighborhoods okay
so here was the question right all of
this was simply about all those curves
how many friends did you have what was
your probability of engaging in the
behavior but we could ask about other
things controlling the number of friends
you have who had say accepted you know
the invitation use the hashtag or
whatever what kind of neighborhood
shapes make you give me the best
prediction that you're going to adopt
okay so here's what we did right want to
compare X versus Y they each have three
friends but what about the structure of
their neighborhoods so here's the data
that we use for this and this is some
work again with a johan Uganda and Lars
Backstrom in with Cameron Marlow who's
also also a facebook we looked at data
from invitations to join facebook so
here's how this works you look at
countries where Facebook is experiencing
rapid growth through a look at countries
where it's already a mature product and
all of these when you join you import
your eat you have the option to import
your address book your email address
book all your address is right so now
but everyone does this or a lot of
people do this and so as a result
Facebook has a bunch of email addresses
of people who are not yet members
because remember sign up for facebook is
tied to your email address so here's
this person and three people have
imported their email address so
Facebook's aware they have three friends
on Facebook
no doubt more but at least three it
knows about from the address books it
offers the newly joined members of
Facebook the chance to invite their
friends it says hey this person is not
on facebook yet would you like to invite
them and you click yes and it mocks up
an email from you saying you know from
you saying hey you should consider
joining facebook it says their email and
it goes and it takes all the people
who've imported that email address and
it puts in the email photos of them it
says here are some people you may
already know who are also on Facebook so
you get this email you aren't on
facebook yet to your inbox and it has
pictures of three people who you may be
no on Facebook because they all imported
your email address and you click you
know yes I would like to join or not so
I've set this up perfectly to have the
pink cloud phenomenon right the pink
cloud is Facebook expanding out you get
an invitation you have three friends on
the site and we know from the facebook
data if those three people are
themselves mutual friends or not so I
can ask the question are you more likely
to accept the invitation if those photos
you see in your invitation letter are
from a mutual set it you know a triangle
or from an independent or from what have
you right I could ask it for all those
topologies okay and so here's what
here's what we see for facebook data and
I should stress that there's a question
you can ask for many domains and I think
I genuinely think and we have some
evidence for this different domains will
behave differently right so this really
about your choosing to join a giant
online social network but not your
decision to join a political movement or
buy a book or any of these other things
right so in this context what we see is
that if your two friends are
disconnected in the invitation all right
so look at invitations with two friends
shown your roughly twice as likely to
accept the invitation as if the two
friends are connected to two friends who
are paired have somehow less
gravitational pull pulling you into
Facebook than two friends were
disconnected you can look at all
remember there were these four possible
triads you could look at every possible
shape that that they could take in the
invitation and you see that it's
monotone increasing the fewer edges
among the people in the invitation the
more likely you are to accept it now it
was interesting we had enough data that
we could actually so this is roughly 50
million invitations that we're looking
at an update that we could take every
possible topology on four nodes all 11
of them
and look at the probability that you
accepted the invitation conditioned on
that being the topology on those four
people in the invitation email and now
it's hard to figure out what to do with
11 numbers right each of them is a
problem empirical probability of joining
and then johan johan your gander Hans
paper had this insight that they
actually broke apart and destroy these
energy bands these different levels
different level set so let me show you
the picture these are the 11 graphs and
these are the empirical probability that
you accept the invitation condition on
what that looked like okay and you see
there's sort of these big flat parts and
there's a step function and what are
those so it turns out these are all the
four node graphs with one connected
component these are all the foreign
aggressors to connecting opponents three
connected components and for Canadian
opponents right so it somehow broke down
to this beautiful step function by the
number of connected components among the
people in your invitation email right
the number of different essentially
social contacts that you were seeing in
that invitation was directly letting me
say something about the aggregate
probability that you were going to
accept the invitation and so in
particular yeah I mean just to really
make this clear right so the claw here
with three edges behaved a lot like the
klique with six edges but quite
different from the triangle and the dot
which also has three digits right edges
was not it it was somehow this this this
this is component camp and of course
they're all sorts of questions that one
wants to do here in particular stuff
we're talking about where it'd be great
to try mixing this with some of the
randomized experiments going on where we
have to try to manipulate what gets
shown and asked you know to what extent
is this something causal in to what
extent is it somehow representing
something about your embeddedness with
respect to Facebook the network okay so
there a whole bunch of issues that I
didn't have time to talk about
explicitly but I just want to sort of
call out and then just like two more
minutes some of it don't get so a whole
bunch of things right so part of this is
you know and this sort of starts to get
a day you know we think about social
advertising we think about getting your
message out to people in a way that will
be effective right there are many ways
to present somebody with information and
a lot of these sites are doing this
billions of times a day and low-level
decisions about how you choose to
present it right house
did in what social context with which
are the exemplars of it which friends do
I show accompanying the message all of
that could have actual big impact on the
extent to which this thing spreads or is
adopted okay and so that's something
that we've been thinking about a lot
we've been looking at this for what we
call conversational curation so this
notion that you're looking at a thread
say a common thread following someone's
status update on Facebook and I'd like
to know what's going to the eventual
trajectory of that common thread will
become long or short will many people
join in will it turn into a conversation
among a few people and it turns out here
to connectivity among the commenters
becomes an important signal so i look at
take the first two commenters on a
facebook discussion thread and here's a
simple question you could ask yourself
is it likely to be longer if those first
two commenters are connected or if
they're disconnected right this sort of
each each is providing a signal in
opposite directions but that becomes a
feature that can go into a gigantic
machine that tries to actually predict
something about the trajectory of
facebook comment cards there's a whole
bunch of work you can look at with
incentives right that if i want
information to spread i can think about
what are the incentive mechanisms i
could put in place to propagate this
information i could for example as
you're a les Commission's co-author
studied incentive recommendation systems
in which you get a bonus if you
recommend something that then gets
purchased right by somebody else I could
look at methods where you actually try
to recruit people and offer them rewards
as inquiry incentive networks which
probe acha raghavan and I thought about
in 2005 in which a variation was used in
the DARPA network challenge in which
teams went out to try to solve real time
mobilization tasks nice work on other
things economic systems like what motion
buh-bye off shard Osinski Segalla ran
into view so hard did with Bitcoin and
the incentives property information
there and of course all of this right
we've talked about structure talk about
behavior these two things are of course
co-evolving right your behavior causes
changes to the structure and the
structure causes changes to your
behavior and we really need to think
about these all together okay so that's
that's sort of a picture of what what we
can do with some of this network data
and so
I want to conclude with one one final
thought here sort of a unfortunately
grizzly image to leave you with just
before the food at the reception from an
op-ed there's a quote from an opioid
that I enjoyed in 2006 which I've used
other times it's from the year of
myspace so bear with me but so june two
thousand six social music becoming big
and this op-ed in Toronto Globe male
complain that myspace w awkward because
it makes public which should be private
doesn't just create social networks then
atomizes them spreads melt like a
digestive tract on the autopsy table you
see what's connected to what who's
connected to whom serve harking back to
an earlier eras are like in the picture
on the right where people first began
taking scalpels to human cadavers and
start looking at stuff and other people
turned away repulsed like don't show me
that right I don't want to see what's
inside what's inside a human body right
that somehow the familiar the things we
live with our suddenly becoming exposed
to us in new ways and part of trying to
learn about them is this is the sort of
shock of simultaneous recognition and
non recognition as we see things that we
have intuitions about and we try to look
at them in new ways right that's
certainly happening with social networks
now that social network have been with
us for as long as we've lived in social
groups but taking large datasets graph
theoretic tools and algorithms to them
is causing us to think about them in
different ways causing us to be able to
actually design systems that make
explicit use of use of them and
certainly the question of the right
frame works for thing about this is a
wide open question as is something
that's been implicit in this talk and I
want to make sure on the final slide to
call it to attention explicitly all the
dangers of stockpiling the this much
data in one place or in a small number
of places and the implications of that
for privacy and and for other things but
I think one thing is clear and you know
I think one thing has been clear through
you know a number of the perspectives on
many different Sciences throughout the
course of today which is there's an
amazing opportunity for fundamental
models in computing to really inform the
next steps in these kind of dialogues as
they take place across many different
sciences thanks very much
you
sure happy day questions
and
sorry so when what's out here for a
while when people are not connected
people more likely to accept here yeah
so right so yeah thanks for the question
so the question is why is it what's the
intuition or what's what's a theory for
why is it when people are not connected
you're more likely to accept the
invitation so there's sort of a whole
kind of rich line of work in social
networks dating back to the 70s and 80s
associated people like Mark granovetter
and Ron bird has I mean nice articulated
two competing forces which I think are
wrestling in that picture one is the
power of closure which says that if my
friends are connected it gives me sort
of a sense of trust that we're all part
of a coherent social group and it also
means that essentially like you know if
I'm dealing with you know with you and
we have many mutual friends our
interactions are sort of safe because
bad behavior by either of us will be
seen by whole into people and
disapproved of whereas if I deal with
someone where we have no friends in
common it's risky because if one of us
miss behaves there's no one to kind of
disapprove right so this notion of
embeddedness creates trust advantages
and so for example i think if we were
looking at someone deciding to join say
a protest march or a peace movement or
something then having friends were
connected might actually the thing my
tilt might be the opposite because
there's a truss advantage on their hand
open network so my friends are
disconnected has a different kind of
advantage which is it gives me
independent endorsements I'm trying to
tell whether to believe a rumor and if I
hear it from both you know a co-worker
and a cousin who lives far away that's
like I'm hearing a to independence or
suppose if I hear it from the two people
down the hall to work with me it's like
hearing it once and so I think what's
being balanced here is the trust
advantages of having closed
neighborhoods versus the endorsement
advantages and I think with what this is
saying in the context of Facebook in
particular is that to the extent we
think of Facebook as a way to manage the
disparate parts of your life seeing that
in fact disparate parts of your life are
all have all adopted Facebook it
actually sort of increases the appeal to
you so I think that's that's that's
that's sort of part of it but yeah it's
it's a very question
you're part of the social sciences rod
and yes it going to the Signet other
provider 54
this time the latter update of the
plenty of questions to ask and you can
run your way more than any of lemon on
this paper so what's happening to the
field how does it sleep out reform from
there right things to follow the big
question yeah so so the question was as
big data enters the social sciences
what's what's the effect on on the
mainstream practice of social science
research right so it's a you know it's
interesting of course I you know I think
all feel to trying to wrestle with what
are we gonna do with data how's it going
transform the field and you know
different fields are at different stages
in development and different styles of
research and going to affected
differently I think in the social
sciences one thing it's sort of calling
you know into its bring into into sharp
focus and this is an interesting point
is that you know all fields have axes
along which they vary you know and we
can think of several and computer
science one that is a big one I would
say this is me speaking as you know
someone who is sort of working with
sociologists but you know me watching
them my sense is one axis along with
sociology varies is from substantive to
methodological as in are you some as a
computer science approaching this we
think I would like methods that allow me
to analyze social phenomena across many
different settings in which social
phenomena take place but someone who has
a particular what we call substantive
interest in social sciences they might
be a sociologist of adolescence or a
sociologist of aging or protest
movements or unemployment or of life and
cities or poverty right these are all
very hard social problems and one could
take a domain dependent view and say I'm
going to study that because I'm trying
to solve real social problems and i'm
going to understand everything I can
about that and then you're going to use
big data differently right you're gonna
want data that really comes from that
domain and helps you inform inform
policy in those areas for example and
you're going to naturally question the
you might almost say assumption that i
never even articulated here that
learning about social phenomenon in
domain x is gonna give me insight into
how social phenomena play out in domain
y right and so if i come with say data
from how people behave on facebook
someone who studies the sociology of
cities might say so explain to me how
this maps over right and so I think that
kind of mapping exercise is going to go
on also as we take you know deep
substantive concerns that sociologists
have those who are working in specific
domains and think about what is the
transfer going right and you know and
notions like you know domain transfer
and maybe even transfer learning come
into play where we say you know to
extend is this domain of social sciences
like that one into y sent can
accumulating a ton of data here help me
learn about this other one where it's
hard to get data so i think that's
certainly one of the conversations
that's that's going on now so some parts
of the social sciences sort of
immediately see how to use it other
parts for genuine reasons are sort of
asking the question you know how can we
best make use of this and is it really
going to help us Peter you a data
questions
just shows the two of the
Yeah right question so if if I only show
those two so what's what's shown here is
these are people where this was all the
friends where they didn't pour the email
address so that manipulation is
something that we would love to do
actually and actually to answer your
question with a slide let me sneak in a
slide that this is the randomized
experiment so this is sort of as far as
these randomized experiment have gotten
but it's it's a nice one to look at it's
exactly your questions scaled back a
little bit let's look at the bottom half
of the slide right so it's this question
of causality which people in the social
sciences might call the puzzle of
homophony versus influence so you know
if I tell you have three friends who
like mountain biking versus one you're
more likely like mountain biking but is
that because they convinced you were
just because I mean you've got three
friends like mountain biking you must be
a mountain biker right so here's how
they tested that they said all right
let's separate those two effects
similarity versus actual influence I
take a page on Facebook that you can
like or not I take some of those three
friends who actually liked it and in
condition one I show them a single
friend who likes it I hide the other two
condition to I show two out of the three
and a condition three I show all of them
so now you really had three friends but
I'm going to control and chances are you
don't actually know all the friends who
like this page so you probably don't buy
out of the amines know about the other
ones and so let's look at your chance of
clicking like on the page so if you have
one friend I show them to you let's call
that a click rate of one point oh it's
some low probability but the point is
will normalize it if you had two friends
and I show one of them to your already
twenty percent more likely to click
because the second friend of course
means you're more predisposed for that
page the extra friend adds another
whatever fifteen twenty percent and the
same thing happens with three right so I
can start to tease those apart so this
our way of saying there is a methodology
where I can randomize that and what
you're suggesting is exactly what we're
talking about trying to architect to do
it with the topologies also yeah
taking carpeting Satan's going to do
there are a number of different kind
these behind the nose
please yeah
the IRS has its own
but so do when technology there
saying that
yeah as well as
so for those notes with
those real-world portlets that are human
individuals
you see any difference
right yeah yeah okay so the question was
on a site like Facebook you have
different thing you have people who have
friends but then you have like a page
like an advertiser like the IRS like
coca-cola who can also have friends or
followers or you know whatever they're
doing subscribers so yeah so what I'm
showing here are people who registered
as people and it's controlled to be that
they actually had regular usage and
hadn't been flagged by the spam
heuristics right so a lot to be able to
sign up fake accounts you know spam
prevention tries it's best and so these
were people who passed all those filters
and were under all the heuristics that
we had people so it's not testing these
other entities this actually I'm yeah
the site's back to a point which I
mentioned summer in the mill they that
there are sort of in a sense to very
interesting graphs in online social
systems and studying how they
intermingle and superimpose with each
other is always interesting right one is
the friendship graph write the notes are
human beings and the links represent
actual mutual bilateral friendship or at
least acquaintance [ __ ] and the other is
the awareness graph where the nodes are
you know people sentient beings
organizations you know papers articles
whatever and a links to be if a is aware
of be right you know so think if you
just want to keep the nodes to be people
think about difference between the
global friendship graph and the global
name recognition graph right Nicole name
recognition graph think of the degree of
someone like Barack Obama you know the
degree of someone like Bill Gates right
it's its enormous because they don't
need to cognitively scale up to him and
they have to killing the scale up
someone but to be able to handle the you
know millions hundreds of millions of
people who have heard of them so yeah so
those two graphs play together they're
super impose I would argue on Facebook
less so right in the sense facebook has
been moving in the direction of trying
to look more like that I'll sound like
Twitter those two things are just mashed
up completely right because you've got
people with a million followers who are
either celebrities or corporate entities
or whatever and they've got people
direct messaging each other who are
essentially using it as a friendship
domain and so Twitter I think is
particularly interesting because it's
sort of a publishing medium superimposed
on a friendship graph and
and there's a lot of interesting work
along the lines you mentioned to try to
disentangle those two uses a site like
that and I think a lot of sites you can
sort of classify along a spectrum how
much are they like the French of graph
and how much they liked the name
recognition graph and sort of wherein in
between do they sit and that's sort of
one way to lay out a bunch of different
social media sites on that on that
conceptual spectrum each around
inside using a fairly basic graph do it
he thinks I'm just one
whether you think the vehicle involved
is using somewhat more structured data
such as you know
Piper rats are we
you know for instance Facebook has got
was close friends yeah maybe he
contracted AIDS away from these things
and privacy like some insights on my
hand impossible she didn't hear his
future you know that direction yeah I I
think so and so to get back to to my
claim the beginning that in a sense
graphs of one they've carved out this
conceptual territory there's a good
thing and a bad thing with winning right
the good thing is that you've worked
reality so that people think in terms of
graphs and then lets you do a lot of
analysis and design things the bad news
is that they've warped reality and so
it's then hard to kind of look beyond
and but yeah I think it has been
surprising and I I'm guilty of this as
someone else's that more use isn't made
at the very least of weighted graphs I
mean every edge on facebook we know you
know how much did they messaged each
other how much does a profile view each
other how much are they co tagged in
photos and I have a slide which I also
admitted omitted here where I looked a
bit at the number of co appearances in
photos we've been tied together is a
great measure of sort of how much are
you sort of it so yeah so I think
weighted edges is certainly one step
hypergraphs is a great great question
one thing we've been looking at is say
you look at it sorry I mentioned
invitations to events for example right
so I take you know five people and I
look at how all the different events
we've invited to project onto them
that's now actually some kind of a
simplicial complex or something where
you can ask all sorts of fascinating
questions and we're talking look at some
of that so yeah I think you know graphs
is where the base but I think we want to
both annotate it with you know ante was
way its ante with text right what is the
text to travel across ledges and we've
looked a bit about at the question you
know for every edge I can annotate it
with to what extent of the two people
matching each other's language styles
across that edge to show something of
that but the kind of how in sync the
interaction is and then these larger
structures like I progressed absolutely
right sure
or a constant yeah so yeah great
question yes so when i said when i said
to i should have said a small constant
number so in fact here's one thing we
did we we asked the question so you're
more likely to join in when you have
more components just does that carry
over to once you have once once you've
actually now you're on facebook you've
acquired friends we looked two weeks
into your time on facebook said what is
your network look like and how engaged
you'll likely be six months out and is
it something in the gret in the graph
theoretic structure that would help us
predict that so now components is too
weak because they're also two reasons
why two components come together so
basically what we did was we use but
clicks are too strong because they're
not really CLE so we use was the cake or
so for those of you don't know the cake
or I start and I take all nodes of
degree less than K and decide that
they're sort of irrelevant for my
purposes because they have so few
connections I delete them that of course
reduces some people's degrees i delete
those I delete those I keep going until
I have a sub graph in fact the maximal
sub graph where everyone has minimum
degree kit that's the cake or so I
basically taken your neighborhood and
I've ripped out all the people who are
sort of in consequentially there and
I've kept the people who serve robustly
there and that now I count components
and and what's cool is that your
engagement six months out is actually
monotonically increasing with the number
of components you have so there is this
variation and so that's my analog of
sort of cleek since clicks is too much
requirement number of cake or components
turns out to be nicely correlated with
how engaged and the more cake or just as
number of components increases your
chance of accept the invitation more
cake or components means you're more
likely to login say six out of seven
days per week six months out if you have
more of these which again to get back to
sha fees question is something about to
the extent maybe maybe so they sent that
Facebook is letting you manage multiple
spheres of your life you're more likely
to use it as a as a place that you
returned yeah
good question reception that's good okay